この家ですね。新居に来てから
２ヶ月ぐらいが経ったんですけども
え～今のところこの新しい家
はじめアミューズメントパークの来場者数は・・・
[ドラムロールの音]
ジャーン！
３名でございます！
ありがとうございます！
パチパチパチパチパチパチパチパチ...
まじかぁ～・・・
もう～バレてる
もう～俺んちに人が来たぞ
もうもう来た
もう来た！
おい！そこの中学生３人！！見てるか？
人が来たので家を引っ越して、その家もさらに引っ越して
今のこの家に来たんですけども
もう！！
ちょっとね。３人ぐらいちょっと
動画を見てくださってありがとうございます
じゃない！！！
動画を見てる人が３人、僕の家に突撃してきました
非常に迷惑です
正直もう何か怖くて外にも出たくないんですよ。今あんまり
それぐらいね　ちょっとね　家に直接来られると非常に迷惑っていうことを　まずね
何回も言ってると思うんだよ！！
何回も言ってるんだけども
それでも俺んちに来るやつがいる！
あんあｎ・・・もういいよ　特定してもいいよ
特定してもいいし、はじめがどこに住んでるかってのわかってもいいんだけども
直接家に来られると、ちょっとね迷惑なんですよぉ～
ホントにもぉ～・・・
僕寝てて、こう部屋で
寝ててピンポン気付かなかったんですけど
寝てて、こう、ドンドンドン！ドンドンドン！ってきて
それがもう結構長い時間・・・３０分ぐらいかな
で、最近そういうなんか
視聴者さんが家に来るってのがなかったんで
ちょっと気が緩んでた
ちょっと気が緩んでてて
ガチャって開けると
「えっ！ヤベェ！本物だ！えっ！おい！はじめちゃちょー本物だ！！」
みたいな・・・
本物だけども・・・
本物だけども！！！
知らない人が家に来るのはホントに怖いんですよ
前だってちょっとニコニコして
「お前ら誰にも言うなよ」つって写真撮ってたんですけど
何回も動画に言ってるのにまだ来るってことは
ちょっとまだ駄目だなと思って
とりあえずね　もうちょっと特定始まってる
この動画を見てるお前たち
俺の家がわかっても来るなよ
俺んちに来ても俺は何もしないぞ
もうね　ほんと迷惑だからもう…普通に怒っちゃうんで
あの～　僕の家がわかってもね
特定してもいいです
ここがはじめン家かってわかってもいいけど
家の周りの写真を撮ったりピンポン押したり
なんかずっとドンドンとかね、されるととても迷惑なので
やめてください
とても迷惑なので
で、今回ね
やっぱ怖いんですよ
もし俺んちがわかって来る人が
もし、犯罪者とか物を盗みに来た時の
対処をね　今日はちょっと
しｔｒ、しようと思います
もうね　アレだよ
小学生中学生関係なく俺んち来たらオレは怒るからね？
ていうことで今回はこちら！
防犯カメラです。
おれはもう家に防犯カメラ取り付けるからな
お前ら俺んちの前に来ると俺は動画を撮って・・・
カメラ画像でスマホですぐに見られます。て事で、スマホで確認できる防犯カメラを買ったので
これを今日から家に取り付けて勝手に人の家に来るバカ共を
俺はこれでね撮るからね！
俺はね怒ってるからね！
そこの中学生！
怒ってただろ俺！
ちゃんと証拠残すのでそのまま通報します
これが防犯カメラです
これで後ろのＷＰＳを３秒押します
１２３ほい！
あ、めっちゃ点灯している
一分以内に無線LANのＷＰＳボタンを押さなきゃ
どれだ～？
ＷＰＳボタンー？
え、違う違う
WPSボタンー？
どれー！？ わかんないよ！
え！？
わかんない！
WPSボタンてどれ？
ええ！？待って！
どれだろう？
わかんないよ！
え！？
あ＾あ！！
okこれでアプリと連動させれば！
え！？もうこれダメじゃん！
接続中なのかな？今？
なんとか接続ができたんですけど...
ちょっとねー
面倒くさっかった
アプリがもうちょっと改善されれば使いやすいと思います。
Today's hajimen point
brrrr
ばぁん！
YON!
[ぱぁん！]
勝手に人の家に行って３０分もドンドン(ドアを叩く)するのはとても怖いし、もう犯罪チック
そうゆうのは、大人でも、子供でも関係なくやっちゃこ..お　おとn(ry
やっちゃダメなんです。そういうのはやめましょう
という訳でもう監視カメラ仕掛けるからね
これから俺んちに来るやつは…全員俺が録画しとく！
じゃあ監視カメラ仕掛けてきまーす
へっへっへー
ピーンポーン(インターホン)
あの…今なんか監視カメラに 人影が映ってるんですけども
ちょっとねなんかこの前来た男の子っぽいんで
今回は動画でガツンと言ってあげましょう。
今も来てます
ちょっとガツンと言うんで…！
おい‼(怒)
ガシャン